all right so the supreme court did not
release its hotly anticipated abortion
decision today but there was still a
heavy presence of demonstrations outside
of the court now ask yourself is the
biden white house committed to making
sure that there aren't going to be riots
when that decision finally comes down we
know that they didn't take advantage of
donald trump's 20 000 troops that he
authorized on january 4th in
anticipation of big crowds on january
6th but nobody wants to talk about that
now because far left groups like jane's
revenge are now calling for violence
take a look at your screen you see those
flyers they're now in dc today they read
quote the night the supreme court of the
u.s overturns roe v wade hit the streets
you said you'd riot and addie to our
oppressors if abortions aren't safe
you're not either remember this is the
same group that has taken responsibility
for attacks on pregnancy centers and
said it was open season on pro-life
americans here with reaction wisconsin
senator ron johnson his re-election race
is imperative all right so we know it's
illegal to intimidate and harass
a a judge uh is in it against the law
also to make a terroristic threat and
isn't that a terroristic threat
well sean it is outrageous that you
don't have the bite administration
condemning this intimidation you don't
have democrats speaking out against it
and if you remember chuck schumer on the
steps of the supreme court threatening
justice gorsuch and kavanaugh saying
you've unleashed the whirlwind uh you
will pay the price you won't even know
what hit you sean turn the tables can
you imagine if a republican
congressional leader had uttered those
words issued that threat against a
liberal justice first of all that
republican congressman person would not
be in congress they would have had to
resign in shame and they certainly would
have been elected majority leader of the
senate like democrat sanders elected
chuck schumer so
again it's outrageous that democrats
don't condemn this uh threatened
violence the real violence you know we
had one of our family action groups uh
firebombed in madison
finally the fbi saying they can start
investigating this but this is way too
little way too late
so the january six committee has sworn
uh testimony under oath that in fact
people in the room were there when
donald trump authorized up to 20 000
troops as required by law the
jurisdiction then moves to nancy pelosi
and muriel bowser they steadfastly in
spite of intelligence reports refused to
call in the guard now that we have this
threat
is the country going to be prepared for
what might happen what they say they
will do
well again what we'll see is democrats
just won't condemn
the protests which will probably turn
into riots and violence that they didn't
do it during the summer of 2020 when you
had over 2 000 law enforcement officers
injured 2 billion worth of damage they
didn't condemn that they just
concentrate on january 6th and of course
what shows that committee be a total
sham is nobody's asking the question
they should be asking why was the
capital prepared why wasn't it better
protected and who's responsible for the
lack of preparation security we now know
there were warnings sent directly to
schumer's office on january 5th we know
the capitol police had intel two weeks
before
we know the capitol police chief
requested it himself six times none of
that has come out in the hearings uh
senator your race is critical for
republicans if they are to take control
how's your race going real quick
well they've already spent 34 million
dollars against me my website is ron
johnson senate dot com sean you and your
audience have been great but i need more
support i really do ron johnson for
senate dot com if we want to save the
senate seat and it's by the way to do so
the people in wisconsin that money is
not all coming from wisconsin um you've
been targeted i think you're number one
on the democrats list senator thanks for
being with us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else